Speaker 1: All right. Let's do the final Friday
mailbag of 2022. I know we are turning a corner
that in 2023 the emails I get will be positive,
constructive, not anti-Semitic. Who am I kidding?
We know that that's not going to change. It
probably will get worse. All right. Let's get
a mix of things that came in. Remember, info at
David Pakman dot com is where you can email. We
will also sometimes feature a message from
Facebook or maybe something that comes in on
the YouTube channel or whatever the case may be.
I heard from a gentleman and you be the judge as
to whether they really are a gentleman who said to
us on Facebook, you are stupid. Fox News is number
one for a reason. That's true. I don't know that
we would agree on what that reason is. But okay,
FOX News is number one for a reason. I bred
punk your while you are a piece of ass,
you're a pace wrong. You are of course going
on to say you voted for by don video and that's
enough to prove you are capital s stupid F-you
Jesus is coming for you. Send you into Bernie
Lava Cross Jesus. So this is a commentary about a
disagreement this person has with me over economic
policy, as I'm sure you can tell, very productive,
very actionable and very much welcoming debate
rather than shutting it down. Extremely
important. Duane also wrote to me, and I'm
going to be careful with my pronunciation here.
Wayne wrote to me, Fuck, you are pronouns. Now
they Duane said Your Why are you apostrophe ari
two emails in a row first guy uses the wrong your
Duane also uses the wrong wrong you're saying I
am pronouns apparently you your pronouns you never
did answer when I asked Is psychology damage for
a girl like your daughter to see a boy in a dress?
It clearly is to me. To a dumb progressive. I
don't know. I'm doing I'm struggling. And listen,
I know English is my second language. Maybe it's
my my language limitation that makes it difficult
to understand this. I think what Duane is asking
is, is it psychologically damaging for a girl like
my daughter to see a boy in a dress? You know, I
think you could show my daughter just about any
clothing item on anyone and she wouldn't care. She
doesn't know what's going on. That I can tell. You
know, Duane has real problems and of course, fuck
you are pronouns. Could be the name of a band,
quite frankly. Fuck you are pronouns and I would
encourage a band to pick up that name. But when
continuing not to contribute productively to the
conversation, Jenn wrote in about Kerry Lake's
election trial, which fortunately has concluded
with the lawsuit in the trash, which is where it
should be. Jen wrote, quote, Hi, David, huge
fan of your show. I just moved to the Phenix
area from Sacramento, California. A local news
channel here is doing a livestream of the Carrie
Lake election trial, is what they're calling it.
My question to you is, what is this trial going
to solve or uncover? Well, it'll solve nothing
and it will uncover no wrongdoing. And that's
exactly what happened. Jenn continues It doesn't
seem helpful in restoring trust in the election.
That's not what it's for. The MAGA crowd will say
the election was stolen if Lake isn't governor and
of course, Hobbs will be the next governor of
Arizona. I'd love your thoughts on this. Yeah,
Jennifer is completely right, which is, of course,
the trial didn't overturn the election results
because there's no evidence to suggest the results
should be overturned. So absolutely, the Trumpists
will argue, as they are, that the trial itself
was corrupt. And so even though now there's been
a trial and the judge said you haven't actually
provided evidence of a stolen election, so we're
going to dismiss this. Now, it is that decision
that is biased and the court That is biased and
it's this is what we call unending skepticism.
Skepticism is good. Healthy skepticism is good.
Hey, we should be satisfied that elections
were handled properly. Oh, there are claims
from Arizona. Let's explore the claims. None
of the voting machines worked. Okay. Truth is,
a few tabulators briefly didn't work. Even the
RNC has been satisfied that the election was not
rigged. All right, so the tabulator thing probably
isn't good. Well, people weren't allowed to vote.
You look at the affidavits. The affidavits
say people who showed up after the polls
closed weren't allowed to vote. Oh, well, that's
the law. If you show up after the polls close,
if you're not in line at the time the polls close,
you're not allowed to vote. So we were skeptical.
We evaluated the claims. There's no evidence for
them. We now move on. The unending skepticism is
how conspiracy theorists end up in a rabbit hole
out of which they cannot get. And that's exactly
what we saw in Arizona. Peter wrote in and said,
Why the career change? Why did you go from being
an English teacher? I guess Peter maybe should
have been in my class a English teacher to a
political hack. Now, of course, I was never an
English teacher. Maybe Peter has me confused
with some other host. I don't. I don't know.
But there is a lot of people in my audience
painfully confused about what is happening on this
show. Brian wrote in about gun deaths and said,
David, in discussing the subject of guns and
child deaths, you mention the instances when
someone says limiting clip capacity wouldn't have
made a difference in this specific incident. Tell
them no. Maybe not, but it might make a difference
in the next one. Yeah, this is a good point. You
know, as I've said before, I have put forward
10 to 12 suggestions for reducing gun violence.
And no one suggestion would solve every problem
nor prevent every shooting. The suggestions are
widespread and broad. It includes eliminating any
loophole that allows the transfer of a gun without
a background check. As an example, limiting clip
capacity, preventing people under certain ages
from buying certain guns. No one and other things.
No one solution, no one change would be a solution
to every shooting. But altogether, they would make
a difference in total. And isn't it still good to
reduce gun deaths even if you can't prevent every
gun deaths? Isn't it better to prevent some,
particularly when you can do so without placing
any undue burden on gun owners? Oh, a background
check. Okay. And without violating the Second
Amendment to the Constitution seems worth doing
to me. And Brian has a good addition, which is.
Well, maybe it wouldn't have prevented that one,
but it might prevent the next one. I like it.
Garrett wrote in, seemingly obsessed with my party
ID. Now, as many of you know, I'm not a Democrat.
And what I mean by that is it's just a binary
thing. Have I ever been registered as a Democrat?
No. Have I ever donated to the Democratic Party?
No. I'm not a Democrat. Okay. Garrett wrote in and
says, You are a Democrat. Hi, David. Can you just
embrace that? You're a Democrat? I saw you once
slightly rant about how you're a social Democrat.
I don't even know what that means. I mean, you
can try to explain. I don't think you could. So
Garrett's already confused. Democrat capital
D. Democrat, which is what he's talking about,
is a political party. Social democracy is a
political ideology. It's not even one or the
other. These are different categories of things.
Now, some countries have a social Democratic
Party. When I say I'm a social Democrat, I'm not
talking about an allegiance to a party. I'm saying
my ideology is I'm a progressive social Democrat.
In terms of party membership, I'm not a member of
the Democratic Party. Two different things. Okay.
Garrett goes on, It would be like, well, I believe
in a strong social safety net free, regulated
enterprise. Bravo. We all do. You seem like,
by all plain definitions in U.S. politics, a
Democrat. So just be one. You're not special
unless you have some example as a self subscribed
social Democrat who you're a huge supporter for.
Who is that? Who is the big politician you love?
Who is not a Democrat? And if you say who it is,
please tell me their policies are any better than
just a regular Democrat. I'm pretty sure you are
just a Democrat, which is fine, but live your
life. Cheers. Garrett from New York City. Listen,
Garrett, I don't know why you're so obsessed with
my party ID, but I can't say it any other way.
And if you're not understanding, I don't know what
to do. I am not a member of the Democratic Party.
The way I describe my views is that
I am a progressive social Democrat,
which is a regulated form of capitalism.
Now everybody's policing my speech. She's
okay. Last one. Hey, instead of the December
24th donation thingy, can't you sell David
Pakman and fees? I seriously would pay $99 to help
support your great channel. But I want to see you
in an astronaut suit, please. I know. Instead
of doing the charity fundraiser we did. I should
have done what Trump did, which is I should have
simply offered digital trading cards of myself
in all sorts of strange and bizarre outfits. I'm
sure they would have sold out in a day just like
Trump's. But no, we're not doing that. We did the
charity fund drive. And I think it was the right
decision. We've got a great bonus show for you
today. Get instant access to the bonus show by
becoming a member. It join Pacman Dotcom. Not
only will you get access to the bonus show,
you will also get commercial free audio and video
streams of the show every day, hours before we
publish them for everybody else. It's cheap, it's
quick. It's easy. It's a great way. Heading into
the new year to support independent media that you
believe deserves support. Join Pacman dot com. You
can use the coupon code 24 starts now and
we will see you on today's bonus check.